there's a lot of hard problems in
science but only one of them is called
the hard problem and that's
consciousness how does the big pink
squishy thing inside my noggin interpret
my entire experience of life to find
that out I have trapped a neuroscientist
in an elevator so I'm gonna go get her
to explain
we better go she's been in there a while
[Music]
like so one of my favorite things is
that I just get to come in and ask a
bunch of really difficult questions and
somebody else has to answer them and I
hear that what I'm asking today is
actually sometimes called the hog
problem yeah it's a really hard problem
this one people have been trying to work
this problem out for thousands of years
yeah great well you have an elevator
ride to try and explain it to me do my
best okay ready yeah what is
consciousness well from a
neurobiological perspective
consciousness is our kind of brains
awareness being aware of our inner self
are in a world and the world around us
okay that sounds pretty simple what
makes it hard well we don't exactly know
how the brain creates that experience it
doesn't really seem to exist in any
specific part of the brain instead
something to do with different regions
and different networks in the brain
having conversations and sending
messages back and forward while it
really nice analogy is to think about it
as being like a theater so we have a
stage with a spotlight and sorry what he
was on the stage in the light is what's
in our conscious awareness what we kind
of noticing at that point of time and
then you've got you know what's in the
wings and backstage and the orchestra
pit and all that's kind of going on so
we might even have thoughts happening
backstage we're not aware of so
backstages subconsciousness that's one
way to think about it but you know when
you have an aha moment the insight that
maybe when a thought that's been
backstage kind of comes into our
conscious awareness okay what
unconsciousness yeah that is a really
good question and it's really hard from
a neuroscience perspective to measure
that because oh we're at the talk we're
halfway through yeah seems totally easy
it's fine we all experience being
unconscious everyday when we like in
deep sleep or when someone's had a
general anesthetic or if you know
something a comer it's important to
define consciousness and understand
unconsciousness because that is going to
inform end-of-life decision making is
this stuff going on in their
subconscious that we just can't measure
so is it possible for us to create
consciousness through like AI or
anything like that that fits a lot of
the definitions of consciousness oh my
gosh what happened did I was very
conscious of that experience eyshan mmm
hi what's stuck in the elevator it's not
moving please come back
[Music]
I think I think it's working again okay
let's try oh yeah it's moving I think
which good really fast tell me where are
we so so what's happening in the brain
when you're conscious versus unconscious
what does that actually look like well
we can use fMRI or brain imaging to get
a look at what neural signatures look
like someone who's unconscious signals
are coming into the brain but they're
not moving around they're decoupled the
conversations are sort of stopped so
what does that mean so there's still
messages being transmitted but then
they're not going anywhere else the
different parts of the brain are and
communication with each other and that's
why we think it's that communication
those networks talking that's where
consciousness is somehow imagined is
there a difference between unconscious
in say a medically induced coma versus
sleep that's a really good question if
someone's in deep deep deep sleep we
don't see the same your signatures that
we do in someone who is anesthetized but
someone who has an exit eyes that does
have a similar neuro signature to
someone who is perhaps in a vegetative
state or a coma are humans the only
things that are conscious because I
would instinctively say no but probably
not because we think that our
neurobiology creates consciousness but
whether or not other animals like my dog
for example has the ability to reflect
on his own thoughts one of the problems
with consciousness is we rely on people
being able to explain the experience of
it to us and dogs don't have language to
be able to do that and everyone
experiences stuff differently I guess
that's why it is such a hard problem
because it comes back so much to our own
personal experiences and sense of who we
are we now have the shared experience of
getting stuck in this elevator for a
short time with that that whole drop of
that sudden stop that whole life death
Clary and I expected
thank you so much
when I walked out of the lift on that
one it seemed pretty simple and on
further reflection I think that's
because humans all have a pretty and
Nate idea of what consciousness is we
all experience it but if you were to
think about someone in a vegetative
state in a coma that you know doesn't
seem to have much brain activity you
would not necessarily feel a whole lot
of moral qualms about giving them a
quiet end to life you would often I
guess think of it as being quite kind
but is that right if we can't measure it
if we can't measure if someone's
conscious we just know that they're
unresponsive and they don't have a lot
of brain activity and we choose to end
their life is that the right thing to do
could they still be conscious and we
just don't know it so I think
consciousness is a really big tricky one
a lot trickier than I thought it was
when we started and I think we're gonna
need a taller building for this one
if you want to see more videos from us
then hit the subscribe button and you'll
get an alert when we post something new
and you can expect something about next
week
[Music]